have you ever heard the term attention
economy if you haven't heard it you're
gonna start hearing it a lot
I believe that passion is another word
for energy that's it you don't have to
hang out with people you don't like
there's a pro-life tip for everybody
wanna soar get a mentor what's up belief
nation it's Evan I believe in you and
this channel is designed to be a part of
your daily success routine so today
let's learn from one of the best Mel
Robbins and how to make 2019 your best
year ever
mentor me Mel also if you want to know
what Mel Robbins and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below if you didn't give
what anybody else thought what's the
thing you would love to be doing with
your life I know that everybody's
problem comes down to one pattern you're
repeating that you can't see when you
have an intention on something that you
want to change about your life your
brain helps you
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one value your own attention have you
ever heard the term attention economy if
you haven't heard it you're gonna start
hearing it a lot because that's what we
live in right now it means that people
and companies make money when they have
your attention and in the world of
Internet technology social media your
attention is for sale and what I want to
do in today's mentoring session is I
want to shift your attitude about how
you value your own attention so got a
simple question for you do you use a
phone or a computer to make money or to
improve your life or does the phone use
you to make money what look at this I
lifted it up and it started playing a
video check it out it's on Facebook
right now every time you are on your
laptop and you go onto a laptop and you
start scrolling mindlessly through
Facebook someone else is making money
you ever thought about that like I'm
gonna just scroll through Facebook right
now oh here's a post about yoga tights I
don't need oh and here's something from
BuzzFeed about cute group photo of 23
baby pandas trying to make you know
who's making money right now
whoever made this video and so is
BuzzFeed and so is Facebook but I'm not
they're making money off my attention
and as I keep scrolling oh here's
somebody that's doing something related
to the news and here's another thing ooh
chocolate chip peanut butter cup lasagna
cake am i making money and I improving
my life by right no but guess what
tasty video is and so is Melissa's
southern style kitchen who sponsored
this post so why am i pointing this out
to you I'm pointing it out to you
because the engineers at Facebook the
engineers at every website they they
understand something they understand
that the longer that you spend on their
website or reading their emails or
clicking their stuff the more money
they're gonna make see you and I are up
against a massive amount of Technology
and people that want to trick us into
giving them our attention there's a
reason why Facebook has an algorithm
where they put things in your newsfeed
that you like it's because research
shows that you'll actually stay longer
and how does somebody make money in the
attention economy well they make it by
grabbing your attention so I want you to
consider something today I want you to
be really mindful about your attention I
want you to be mindful about how you're
using your phone and your computer are
you using it to get ahead and to make
more money and to do the things that are
important to you or are they using you
to make a buck as you're going about
your day just notice am i picking up my
phone to use it to improve my life or
make my goals happen or am i picking up
my phone and letting somebody else use
me to make money rule number two make
decisions that energize you
I believe that passion is another word
for energy that's it what do you have
energy for what energizes you and that
we naturally have a tremendous amount of
body wisdom about that and that every
one of us has an internal fuel tank that
is either empty or full and if you're
empty you feel depleted if you're full
you feel energized and so if you simply
are in any situation I mean any
situation and you pay attention within
five seconds to does this person
energize me do they deplete me where are
they in the scale you just gain some
tremendous wisdom and you the simple way
to start to figure out who you are and
what you want is start aligning yourself
with more things that energize you so
situationally if you're lying in bed and
the snooze alarm goes or the alarm goes
off and you feel depleted and you start
reaching for the snooze button that's a
really big sign that you need to get out
of bed now being depleted versus
energized has nothing to do with whether
or not things are hard or easy and
to do with what naturally actually
either expands you or shrinks you and so
if you look at your client list and
measure it depleted versus energized
what shrinks versus expands me you have
the actual map and when you start to
find the courage to make decisions that
energize you and that expand you whether
they're scary or not that's when
everything changes and so that's how I
actually make business decisions is this
I don't even like the money conversation
comes second it's does this deplete or
energize me and if it depletes me how do
you move it in that direction or how do
I stay sane oh if it energizes me how do
I do more because if you are energized
or expanded by something you will do it
for no money you will do it happily and
you will suddenly wake up and say oh my
gosh like my heart I'm pursuing my
passion how did that happen rule number
three take action too many of you are
sitting around waiting to feel ready you
can still move forward when you're not
ready too many of you are waiting to
feel like you deserve to make six
figures it's about the action your mind
your history your past you will always
have a million excuses not to do it not
to feel like it now to believe
yourself they're all the only thing that
matters in your life and your business
is the actions that you're taking and
then more consistently that you take
action the faster you will start to
believe in yourself because you will see
proof that you are not the kind of
person that sits around and feels
unworthy that you're not a victim that
sits by and get sucked into other
people's stuff that you're not that kind
of person so it won't make sense to
believe it anymore but it starts with
action I believe in all of you and I
believe in your ability to get it done
but it's going to be up to you who is
the problem yeah who's the solution
that's right don't wait to feel it and
it's the biggest mistake you could
possibly make it remember that you're
smart remember that you know what to do
and just get it done rule number four be
with the right group of people when I'm
with cooler or popular guys I feel
inferior and worthless which affects me
and weirdly I try so hard to impress
them and be like them like a chameleon I
try to avoid them but I feel left out
whatever I do I feel sad or useless what
can I do in order to overcome this you
don't have to hang out with people you
don't like there's a pro life tip for
everybody you don't have to one of the
things that is a massive indication that
you're hanging out with the wrong group
of people is that you don't feel
comfortable being yourself the second
you try to be somebody else or you feel
like a chameleon just to fit in you are
trying to fit in with the wrong group
relationships only work when you can be
the real you people thrive on energy
that's what drives connection you're
with people that make you wither and
hide and feel insecure you are with the
wrong people
if it's hard to be around people you're
with the wrong group of people when
relationships work they work because
they click and the reason why they click
is because you can be the real you they
don't make you feel inferior you're
making yourself feel inferior by hanging
out with people and pretending you're
not yourself so every time you're
hanging out with a group of people and
you act like a chameleon you're actually
invalidating yourself because your own
actions are telling you you're not good
enough to just be yourself around these
people so the only way to deal with this
is either show up with that group of
people and be your full self and every
time you think something inferior just
knock that thought out of your mind say
what you really believe be interested in
what you're really interested in or the
easier route honestly drop the popular
kids and find your people you need to
find your people and your people are the
kind of people that the second you hang
out with them you don't feel like less
of yourself you feel like more of
yourself you don't feel like you got to
hide or be somebody else you feel like
you want to express yourself and show up
and be more of yourself that's the
indication that you have found your
people rule number five get honest with
yourself
I've always wanted a six pack and I
don't have it and I don't know and I've
never had it and when I I finally
stopped complaining about it when I got
honest about what it was gonna require
I'm dead serious dead serious about this
at my you know at forty nine with my
affinity for alcohol and my love of
carbs and my distaste for exercise I
have a small problem on my hands if I
want a six-pack so if you were to go
forward right and think okay well if a
year from now I had a six-pack what
would what would that actually what
would my day-to-day life look like
and you can get very clear that you're
not committed to that and then you can
stop beating yourself up for the never
intend on doing what I realized is I can
spend four minutes a day in a hotel room
or in my bedroom doing planks and my
arms look great and everybody else will
think the rest of my body is in shape
it's like a charm so you might want to
get honest with yourself I can study
doing this I really be a billionaire or
do this do you really because you can
make it happen
you actually can look at all the idiots
that are making money you can make money
but you're gonna have to roll the clock
forward just a year and say okay if I'm
able to put $1,000 a month against my
debt I'm able to make X amount of
dollars a month I'm able to put X amount
of dollars in savings what do I need to
be doing a year from now to make that
happen and what are those habits that
are there a year from now that I don't
have right now and then roll yourself
back to this moment just like I
explained with exercise do I actually
not want to have a Manhattan tonight
nope did I want to go to the gym today
nope
did I am I willing to not eat what I eat
for nope
and my Willa I did my 4 minutes my arms
are looking really good but so bring it
back and then you will have the formula
for pivoting at any moment
you time-travel forward a year you
investigate the patterns that you have
that are giving you the result that you
want and then you back your ass up to
right here right now and you decide am I
willing to do this now if I'm willing
then 5 4 3 2 1 through all the excuses
that are gonna be there when you're
trying to override your operating system
that's how you do it or you have the
reality check like I had which is ocean
but I just like the beach I don't intend
on changing so why don't we get this off
the plate and let's focus on the things
that I am actually committed to and rule
number 6 the last one before a very
special bonus clip is use the
five-second journal Isle of vision
boards and gratitude journaling because
they help me think about what I want and
why this journal it's gonna teach you
how how you make your dreams come true
I created this journaling method a
couple years ago because I wanted to
stop thinking about what I wanted and
actually make it happen this is simple
it's backed by science and it's gonna
help you make your dreams come true with
just a couple minutes every morning let
me show you how it works at the very top
you write down the time place and date
this simple trick gets your present and
grounded in the moment now notice this
is guilt free journaling there are no
dates printed so if you miss a day or
two you're not behind next I'm gonna
give you a superpower this my friend is
your inner compass learning to read your
energy is the secret to greater passion
productivity and living with more
purpose research from the University of
Pennsylvania proves that if you boost
your mood in the morning you actually
increase your productivity all day long
these next two questions will help you
take control of your energy which
changes how your mind perceives tasks
and will make you more confident about
the day ahead and this section right
here it's the secret to having a great
day I want you to identify one project
that matters to you today not two not
three just one when you focus on just
one project a day you leverage the
progress principle it was invented at
the Harvard Business School and it will
change your life and help you be more
productive so you can make your dreams
come true research
proves you get more done when you focus
on less and every day I want you to
focus on just one thing after you write
down your top project I want you to
write down why this project matters to
you when you know your why science says
you're gonna be more inspired and
motivated to get it done now take that
vision and make it your mission write
down one small action yet you're gonna
take today to move your dream forward it
doesn't matter how small it is forward
is forward according to research simply
using this section of the journal makes
you 76 percent more likely to go from
dreaming to doing and if you have any
other thoughts about the project here's
some extra space to play around with
when you move from thinking to doing it
may make you feel overwhelmed so let's
change that attitude with a little
gratitude studies prove that grounding
yourself and something that you feel
grateful for will boost your happiness
and your effectiveness finally I want
you to write down your quitting time yep
you heard me right part of your morning
routine should be deciding when you're
gonna stop working at night if you feel
like your wheels are spinning and you
don't get anything done if you have no
balance between work and life if you'd
love to spend more time with your family
and still feel like the most productive
person you know set a quitting time this
is called Parkinson's law and it's
rocket fuel through your productivity
now let's go over to the next page
everyone works differently so this page
is designed to work for you if you love
making long to-do lists and checking
things off here's the spot if you want
to plan out your day there's a timeline
on the left and if you need a place to
take notes here's a place where you put
them so there you have it the
five-second journal
I've got a special bonus tip for Mel on
how to tweak your habits that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that it's
time for the three point landing
questions time to move from just
watching another video to taking action
in your life or business and if you're
feeling bold leave your answers in the
comments below here we go question
number one where do you need to get
honest with yourself number two what are
the right group of people that you need
to be with and number three what
decision can you make right now that
will energize you
I realized that I need to have a level
of focus and a level of intentionality
that I have not yet cultivated in my
life that they're still that I do that I
put in the way that was fine when I was
operating and achieving at this level
but now I want to go to this level and
so what are those things getting up
earlier being a complete hawk about how
I'm spending my time and attention that
in the mornings when I'm with my family
literally being hyper focused on just
them so that I'm present with them and
then confession I'll literally work for
like 25 minutes and then the ad kicks in
and then I'll find myself folding
laundry for 20 minutes because I allow
myself to get distracted
see that's the thing about habits and
the levels of success that you get to
that when you recognize that jumping to
the next level that you want to get to
is nothing more than just tweaking your
habits a little bit that it's really
that simple you will start to be able to
have quantum leaps and I'm realizing
that I have amazing habits but they have
gotten me to here and if I want to get
to the next level it's gonna require a
level of focus and intentionality that I
haven't demanded of myself before no
drinking during the week being super
super focused on the stuff that's really
important probably hiring somebody
full-time to be a full-time assistant to
help me stay organized and focused in
terms of scheduling and weeding through
all the incoming requests I think it's
just about that about this sort of like
maniacal focus on things that are
important like now is the time and
what's cool is you can make it happen
any time in your life like if there's
some jump that you want to make look I'm
an extraordinarily productive person
I've accomplished a tremendous amount in
the last three years but what it's gonna
take for me to get to the next level and
not destroy the people around me with my
stress and be an amazing leader and be
an amazing mother and be an awesome wife
and actually be an incredible
businesswoman is a level of focus that I
have
never required of myself
if you want more Mel Robbins check out
the top fifty rules video I made on her
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there our minds are designed to stop you
at all costs from doing anything that
might hurt you